this is a emergency that we have never
experienced before and so the control
measures that we need to put into place
have not been adequately going to play
so yeah we are now garen up to that so
we need to move it very fast so that it
doesn't get our control this is going to
challenge all of our development agenda
our infrastructure it's going to
challenge all of the gains we have made
sense we came to power and so the
international community needn't look at
this as an emergency of high magnitude
for us this has been an issue since Mart
a growing issue since March we're now
700 plus individuals have died how was
more not done prior to this time
individual countries can attest to what
they have been doing but when this
started you it was an entirely a new
situation in our countries in the
country that are involved have long
straight borders there are porous
borders people have relative living and
above saw the country there was a lot of
denial because people felt that this was
a scheme maybe two for something else we
believe that the response was there but
it needed to be more urgent and the
decisions we took where to march the
spread is there a timeline where the
president yourself the administration
wants this issue to be contained or
thinks that this issue can be contained
we believe in about a month if we me as
we begin to move with the same vigor and
trying to raise the campaign at level
the present day by bringing in the
sudden Ibaka me
that is all inclusive working with a
look our communities trying to see about
the borders deploying the security that
the police and the the soldiers to make
sure that the health care workers are
protected do you foresee specific
requests to other institutions like the
World Bank or imma that's why we have
the technical committee to do an
assessment of what is required to be
able to bring this situation under
control within the time frame and that
assessment is on course and but we
believed one hundred million dollars the
we're coming move awho but we believe
that we probably would need more than
that UN personnel are drawing down with
the expected pull out in 2015 you look
at issues like it if it isn't in the
last couple months with Ebola is there
has it come to a moment where you your
administration has approached the UN and
requested perhaps an extension of the
timeline these are issues I've been
dealt with because we believe that the
drawdown is also over straighten up
because we have to now be able to put
the place it was personal those
logistics that will no longer be
provided by the peacekeeping forces so
that is a serious challenge and we
believe that the international community
should understand that from where light
year is coming we would not be in
position to close all those gaps that
are going to be left our situation need
to be looked at very carefully so that
all the gains are been made to the help
of the UN peacekeeping forces will not
disappear in a short time corruption has
long been an issue the president has
taken steps do you feel like the steps
are adequate that have been taken and
are there more steps that need to be
taken going forward we all have to be
accountable corruption the way I see it
is not just the matter of
maybe embezzlement is the matter of
putting the place a system that can be
monitored that can put check and
balances into place so we have taken I
wouldn't say adequate but we have taken
measures whether it is in our judiciary
system the legal system the Arab law and
putting into place those practices I
have to do a procurement put in the
place I have to do with governance is
there something that the u.s. both on
the government side and on the private
sector side can learn from China in
terms of how to work in Liberia how to
invest in Liberia we know that we have
chinese investment but we are not used
them as a standard for investment we are
saying that we want investment and not a
handout but an investment that will open
up our economy try to build a right
infrastructure we believe that we also
have something that we can put into this
partnership to make it work